- After I got hurt, it was
painful to sit on the sidelines
and watch other people play sports
and participate and not be involved.
When I started this
interest in photography,
it was an opportunity to
get back into sports again.
My name is Loren Worthington
and I'm a photographer.
When I was 21 years old, I
wanted to be a baseball player.
I was playing one evening
and I hit a great double
that was a lousy triple,
and I slid into third base,
came in contact with
the other player's knee
and it pinched my spinal cord.
The result of that was paralysis.
I'm a C5/6 quadriplegic.
I've been in the wheelchair
for the past 30 years.
It wasn't until almost
20 years after my injury
that I picked up a camera.
Adapting the camera is
kind of an extension
of learning how to deal with a disability.
I cannot use my right fingers.
What I figured out is that I could use
an external shutter control with my mouth
and take the photograph.
The type of photography
that I do is about people
who are involved in
adaptive sports, and I felt
my best photographs were of
people with disabilities
because they saw in me somebody
that they could open up to.
When I take photos of athletes,
I wanna show them as
somebody who works hard,
who competes hard and who wants to win.
It really shows more about the
athlete than the disability.
When I first started
shooting adaptive sports,
I immediately set my goal
to taking photographs at the Paralympics.
I got the phone call
from the United States Olympic Committee
that they were interested in me
going to Rio de Janeiro in 2016.
There was some of the most
amazing athletes there
and it worked out, same as what
I've always had to deal with.
You just gotta try it.
Probably the first day,
it's not gonna work so well
but after that, you just start getting
better and better at everything you do.